ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuántas historias tan lindas para
compartir verdad que pudiéramos
mencionar cuántas historias conforman de
veras nuestra vida llenas de éxitos de
momentos de celebración de alegría de
gozo es así como construimos nuestra
vida cuántos de nosotros no hemos vivido
la experiencia quiénes somos papás
tenemos la dicha de ser padres de vivir
la experiencia de organizar la fiesta de
cumpleaños de nuestros hijos e incluso
puedo mencionar que implica seis meses
nueve meses de planeación un poco no
cuántos de nosotros recientemente hemos
planeado una boda o hemos sido parte de
la organización de una boda o de un
aniversario de bodas incluso podemos
mencionar que es un proceso de más de un
año de planeación verdad son momentos
que van conformando nuestra vida
momentos de alegría dignos de celebrarse
y de disfrutar y no estoy hablando de
celebraciones caras o fastuosas estoy
hablando de los pequeños momentos que
conforman nuestra vida de las cuales
tenemos esa oportunidad de que año tras
año se nos presenta esa oportunidad
se fijan
noble es la vida con nosotros si no nos
despejamos este año el próximo año
tenemos la oportunidad de hacerlo en
grande un pequeño como queramos hacerlo
esto no es la cuestión
la cuestión es reconocer verdaderamente
lo afortunados que somos los seres
humanos la raza humana la especie humana
es la única en toda la creación que
tenemos esta capacidad la capacidad de
organizar una serie de eventos verdad y
en conjunto con esos sentimientos que
evocan felicidad podemos festejar con la
gente que más queremos estos momentos y
lo podemos hacer al estilo norteño el
sano estoy hablando de una fiesta cara o
elegante estoy hablando de que cuantos
de aquí nos celebramos en una carne
asada a nuestro propio cumpleaños real y
si yo los invito a que piensen en aquel
recuerdo el más entrañable que tengamos
de nuestro festejo más bonito que hemos
tenido puedo asegurarles dos elementos
esenciales en esa imagen número uno
personas que queremos que amamos
papás hermanos hijos están en esta
imagen y número 2 un pastel iba a decir
ay qué chiste pues ella es pastelera y
un pastel hay un frente por supuesto que
se viene una imagen de pastel en mi
mente pero ciertamente el pastel tiene
un significado y es por eso que se
presenta en esa imagen el significado
del pastel es el amor que queremos
compartir con nuestros seres queridos en
esos momentos tan gratificantes de la
vida es el momento en el momento más
dulce de la celebración en el que digo
esta celebración la que decido compartir
con todos ustedes es en el momento por
ejemplo como en el de la carne asada en
donde estas son las mañanitas no y en
ese momento cuando se presenta el pastel
oficialmente podemos decir que esa
simple carne asada se convirtió en el
festejo de fulanito de tal verdad
entonces
que el pastel tiene un significado muy
hermoso en nuestras vidas y sin embargo
muchas veces dejamos pasar esas
oportunidades y jugarán este año cumplo
39 años
mejor me festejo cuando sean los 40
tal vez tal es mi caso y digo no estoy
hablando de la cuestión económica nada
más estoy hablando de que si lo queremos
hacer pequeño o en grande tenemos que
saber aprovechar esos momentos pues nada
nos garantiza que el próximo año las
personas con las que queremos celebrar
van a estar y no estoy hablando nada más
de la vida o de la muerte estoy hablando
de la cuestión psicológica es
sentimental
incluso financiera de economía nuestro
en nuestro país puede influir en la
decisión de una fiesta de cumpleaños
verdad si no fuera tan importante el
pastel en nuestras vidas en nuestras
fiestas no habrían tantas mamás
persiguiendo a los hijos en siéntate
para tomarte la foto del halago del
pastel o no fuera tan tradicional verdad
la icónica foto de los novios en una
boda cortando el pastel si ustedes se
ponen a pensar qué significan el pastel
de bodas es ese amor de los novios qué
sé
en tanto que no puede ser contenido en
un pastel pequeño ese es el verdadero
significado es tanto el amor que se
tiene uno por el otro que se desborda y
tanto es el amor que deciden compartirlo
con los invitados se fijan la
responsabilidad que implica para
nosotros los pasteleros y me preguntan
muchas veces cómo le hace rocío es la
pregunta de de toda la vida como la
haces rocío para hacer pasteles tan
bonitos de tanto diseño y conjugarlo con
tu vida deportista con tu vida de
emprendedora con tu vida familiar pues
ciertamente déjenme platicarles un
poquito la vida de los fontán agrest o
los pasteleros que es una profesión muy
moderna conjugamos dos habilidades
básicamente la habilidad de crear
pasteles deliciosos esponjosos cremosos
verdad por el gusto que tenemos de la
gastronomía y la habilidad de
confeccionar cosas muy creativas en
azúcar esas dos habilidades que tenemos
con jugadas nos hacen presentar este
tipo de proyectos
pero aparte le ponemos un poquito más de
sazón a la vida que es la psicología que
implementamos al atender a nuestros
clientes por ejemplo si yo les explico
el proceso de elaboración de un pastel
de bodas es algo complejo déjenme
contarles cómo funciona llega la nuevo
viajante presentan sus ideas y hay que
entender un poquito en dentro de su
estrés pues lo que quiere evocar hay
muchas maneras de encontrar ese
sentimiento si se enamoró en una tarde
de otoño si lo que quiere presentar es
un algo elegante si lo que quiere de ser
es una boda fastuosa si es algo sencillo
simple minimalista si es campirano si es
un agua de la playa todos esos
sentimientos hay que recopilar los y
automáticamente se presenta una imagen
en mi cabeza
ahí está la imagen no
y yo con mis habilidades de repostera
que ya tengo entre paréntesis 20 años
dedicada a la repostería empecé muy
joven pero con esas habilidades con
jugadas con mi imagen en mi cabeza voy
confeccionando todas esas texturas
dimensiones sabores flores de azúcar y
colores que vamos a implementar en el
pastel y hasta que llegamos al momento
de la boda y lo presentamos en ese
momento ya puedo decir que la imagen que
yo proyecte en mi cabeza en la medida
que se parezca a lo que yo presenté en
la boda en esa medida yo puedo decir que
el pastel es exitoso esperando la
respuesta de mi novia que diga wow es el
pastel más hermoso que había visto en
toda mi vida en esa medida yo puedo
decir que mi pastel cumplió el cometido
esa imagen ese poder de visualizar y a
través de las habilidades que nosotros
vamos generando con la práctica
cotidiana eso es lo que me permite
entender quién poderoso es el poder de
la visualización todo empieza con una
imagen en la cabeza y digo
y si yo lo implementó en mi vida
cotidiana por qué no hacerlo en mis
gustos personales por ejemplo yo me
considero una adicta al ejercicio de
alto rendimiento y lo empecé haciendo
como meramente un hobby y sin embargo
esta idea de decir yo tengo esa idea en
mi cabeza de quien quiero ser de lo que
siempre he soñado hacer quiero correr
carreras maratones medios iron mens
incluso carreras porque no competencias
en mar abierto y todo eso es esa misma
imagen así como proyecto la imagen del
pastel en mi cabeza
al igual proyecto la imagen de atleta en
mi cabeza
obviamente acompañado de mucho
entrenamiento y mucha disciplina pero es
así como surge y es así como tantas
historias que pudiera compartir paz pero
la más especial de todas fue la que viví
el año pasado
déjenme contarles que el año pasado hice
una travesía en el mar desde cancún
hasta isla mujeres es una distancia de
10 kilómetros en el mar
entiendan esto es en el mar no hay mundo
ningún lugar donde detenerse
porque ya me estaban un calambre no hay
lugar donde comer no hay lugar donde
sostenerse porque tienes hambre es
brazada atrás el sol en tu cara la
bocanada de agua salada pero es esa
imagen de la mente decir voy a llegar
con los brazos en alto y decir voy a
lograrlo lo que me permite llegar al
final bueno asimismo la proyección de un
sitio siempre querido salir en un
programa de televisión pero no por el
hecho de ser famosa o sea me gusta la
conducción me gusta se pueden dar cuenta
que no que no me da tanto miedo la
cuestión de escenografía podemos decir
que lo dominamos y me gusta y sin
embargo esta imagen me permitió llegar a
dos programas de televisión de que
tienen que ver con la gastronomía
uno de ellos fue utilísima quien
recuerda aquí los grandes iconos de la
gastronomía aquiles chaves benito y
solange antonio de livier luz blanchet
es este programa de televisión que marcó
toda una generación nada podemos decir
que mucha gente se siente identificado
con este programa y también el programa
por supuesto del gran icono pastelero
soy su fan número uno por ciento
el señor bar y balastro quién recuerda
carlos de green
famoso por sus pasteles de altas
dimensiones y se volvió mundialmente
famoso por esos realities que él hizo
bueno esa imagen en mi cabeza también me
dijo por qué no si yo soy su fan número
uno y antes de que él fuera famoso yo ya
lo había proyectado en mi mente decía yo
lo voy a conocer yo le decía a mi esposo
y yo lo voy a conocer no no no no no lo
voy a conocer yo le voy a decir yo
quiero trabajar contigo yo también soy
bueno haciendo pasteles y es esta imagen
por ridícula que pudiera sonar en un
principio porque si sonaba ridículo a la
verdad fue la mente que la que me
permitió llegar al programa de
televisión en el 2016 participe en el
desafío de bar y latinoamérica donde
siete compañeros más luchamos hombro a
hombro por ganarnos el título del mejor
repostero pastelero de toda
latinoamérica y el premio sustanciosos
de 50 mil dólares bueno pudieron decir
guau cuántas historias tan bonitas bueno
no todo es color de rosa
hay ciertamente muchos momentos de
fracaso de tristeza de frustración de
cansancio físico cuando son
entrenamientos de alto rendimiento y
dice uno cómo le haces para superar
superar esas adversidades pues la
respuesta la va a encontrar cada uno de
ustedes en tiene su motor tiene que
haber alguna llama que los incendio por
dentro y decir esta es la razón por la
que me levanto todos los días y la razón
por la que yo siento ese deseo de sentar
un ejemplo en mi familia son mis hijas y
mi esposo es mi familia quien me impulsa
todos los días a decirme hijo la rocío
levántate porque tienes mucho trabajo
que hacer es pensar en grande lo que
siempre me ha permitido proyectar cosas
en grandes por ejemplo cuando yo hago un
pastel de bodas ciertamente pienso en
los novios pero pienso más allá de ellos
pienso en las 200 o 300 personas que van
a estar en este cumpleaños o en esta
boda que también van a probar el pastel
y es así como decido proyectar mi vida
la familia es el pulso es el motor que
me incendia
levantarme todos los días para proyectar
cosas en grande porque este es el
verdadero sentido de la vida podemos
festejar cosas cotidianas o cosas
pequeñas
no importa la magnitud de la celebración
lo que importa es el gozo que llevamos
por dentro y con quién decidimos
compartirlo pues si yo les contara a ver
vamos a tratar de pensar en la fiesta
que más han deseado en su vida la que
más anhelan tener no se limiten en la
cuestión monetaria piensen en grande que
quisieran transmitir en esa fiesta de
cumpleaños decoración piensen en los
banquetes exquisitos que quisieran
servir imagínense las copas llenas
rebosantes de las bebidas más
sofisticadas que pueden imaginar piensen
en la música que quieren ambientar
verdad yo ustedes imagínense en medio de
la pista verdad sentados así paraditos
ya listos que comience la fiesta y estar
completamente solos
se pueden imaginar lo patético y triste
que puede hacer esa fiesta de qué
sentido tiene la vida si no tenemos con
quién compartirla de qué sentido tendría
que yo estuviera hablando de las
maravillas de mi vida o de las miles de
historias que pudiéramos compartir si no
tenemos con quién compartirla es así
como yo edifico mi vida la edificó a
base de pequeñas o grandes celebraciones
y eso es a lo que yo los quiero invitar
a que reflexionemos que todos los días
tenemos oportunidades de celebrar
podemos celebrar en pequeño o podemos
celebrar en grande ustedes deciden que
quieren celebrar pero el sentido de la
celebración está con quien queremos
compartirla ese es el verdadero
significado del pastel es el gusto y el
gozo el momento más dulce de nuestra
celebración que decidimos compartirlos
con todos nuestros seres queridos es así
como yo he decidido voltear a ver al
final de mi vida y decir está conformada
de esas pequeñas o grandes celebraciones
para el final poder decir esta es la
gran celebración de mi vida y yo he
decidido que esta tarde en donde todos
ustedes están presentes
sean parte de esta gran celebración sean
parte ustedes también de la gran
celebración de la vida de ustedes
conforme la con esas pequeñas o grandes
oportunidades que la vida les presenta
pues ciertamente hay momentos de
tristeza y de recogimiento pero también
tenemos que aprender a valorar los
momentos de gozo y felicidad y debemos
de saber quiénes están en esa lista de
invitados porque a veces tenemos que
hacer depuración en las listas nueva
muchas veces es bien difícil poder
conformar una lista y decir fulanito no
entra pero es eso lo que les debemos de
decidir a quién invitamos a nuestras
personas más queridas familias hermanos
y gente que admiramos así que sean parte
de esta gran celebración todos ustedes
son parte de la celebración
ted ex tijuana y los invito a que
prueben de este delicioso pastel porque
lo hice pensando en cada uno de ustedes
gracias por su tiempo y gracias por
estar presente
[Música]
[Aplausos]